it was supposed to unlock Venezuela's
long-standing political deadlock but at
the end of a highly expected
International Conference in Bogota the
announcements showed little concrete
results
how many positions were identified first
the need to establish an electoral
timeline that allows for the holding a
free and transparent elections with full
guarantees for all Venezuelan actors
second that the steps agreed to the
satisfaction of the parties go hand in
hand with the lifting of the various
sanctions representatives from 19
countries and the European Union
gathered in the Colombian capital to try
and force a restart of the talks between
the Venezuelan government of Nicolas
Maduro and the opposition there were
suspended months ago in Mexico
since then Colombian president Gustavo
Petro has become a de facto mediator
between the United States Maduro and the
opposition to try and Forge a road map
out of the long-running crisis one in
which the U.S will agree to lift
sanctions in exchange for free elections
we need to establish a timeline for the
elections and its guarantees the
Venezuelan people need to choose freely
with the sovereignty and without
pressure what they want
the European Union sent a high-level
delegation to the conference signaling
they agreed that the Mexico talks are
the best path forward after having
failed to force a regime change in
Venezuela despite despite years of
economic crisis in the country that
forced Millions to flee on Monday the
conference was almost disrupted by the
unexpected arrival of Juan guaido the
former leader of Venezuela's opposition
who hoped to meet with International
delegates without having been invited
the Colombian government said he had
entered the country legally and that
they allowed him to leave for the United
States why they questioned Petra's
neutrality in the negotiations and said
he feared for his family back home
after 60 hours on the road to get to
Bogota and escaping the persecution of
the dictatorship defying the Madura
regime that taking me out of Colombia
the persecution of the dictatorship
unfortunately has reached Colombia but
in the end Guido wasn't the main problem
the real issue is just how to convince
Maduro to loosen his grip on power the
Venezuelan government insists that
sanctions need to be lifted immediately
including some 3.2 billion dollars have
held in U.S banks for now the
International Community is just hoping
to be able to convince Maduro to sit
down with the opposition again
Alessandra Al Jazeera Bogota